every american city is now a border city
fentanyl is now the leading cause of
death
for americans between the ages of 18 and
45. biden's open border policies are
killing americans why is the white house
not treating this like the crisis it is
fentanyl is now poisoning and killing
hundreds of americans every day as
mexican drug cartels take advantage of
the chaos at our southern border the
white house still refusing to do what
needs to be done to stop them ron
vitiello is the former acting director
of ice and former chief of the u.s
border patrol it's great to have you on
300 americans a day roughly dying of
opioid overdose most of those fentanyl
the white house joe biden didn't mention
it at all last night but it gets even
worse wrong because the white house is
now you know insulting america's
intelligence by telling them that people
aren't just walking across the border
it's not happening
they have no credibility on this issue
the president can't use his prime time
speech to talk about what's going on
with fentanyl and
drug overdoses are going to account for
over a hundred thousand deaths in the
united states this year and so he can't
talk about fentanyl he can't talk about
all the drugs coming across the border
from mexico because that's where 90 plus
percent of them come from he can't talk
about the 700 plus people who are dying
in the pipeline trying to cross that
border because he's going to have to
bring attention to to the disaster that
they've created by pulling down all the
policies that were working at the
southwest border and controlling that
border when this president took over
they had 45-year lows in traffic along
the southwest border now we have a
demand problem with drugs fentanyl is
killing people because a lot of people
don't know they're taking fentanyl
they're buying drugs off the dark web or
off the street corner and they don't
know they're taking
fentanyl inside of something else and so
it's a big problem and and they they
have to avoid it because that brings
attention to the disaster that's at the
border
ron they did ask answer a question from
the white house from our own peter ducey
this earlier this week so we've been
showing all week if you could show call
for number one this is a map showing the
fentanyl gateways into the united states
from mexico and then you had corinne
jean-pierre the white house press
secretary to say to peter ducey this
week well please pull up call for number
two
the fentanyl seizures are up by 200
percent so she said so that proves that
we are doing all that we need to do
because
the cbp has actually seized this much
fentanyl how would you respond to her
saying that they've done their job
well i'm grateful that there are people
out there you know border patrol cbp the
dps you showed earlier that they're
making these seizures and protecting us
from that poison but let's not pretend
that the disaster that's going on at the
border is somehow doesn't exist just
because we made more seizures than we
did last year the reason that there's
more fentanyl in the pipeline is because
these cartels are becoming
more and more emboldened because they
essentially control the traffic across
the border between the ports of entry
and yeah it's great that we catch it but
it's not everything it's not when the
highway patrol goes out and writes three
speeding tickets they don't go back and
tell the people that they work for that
there's nobody on the highway that's
breaking the speed limit that's just not
how it works
i'm glad that they're doing everything
that they can but there's much more that
needs to be done what's the plan for the
border when are we going to continue to
have hundreds of thousands of people per
month crossing the border and giving
these cartels millions and millions of
dollars a day yeah and i guess that's
the question right there i mean what is
the plan what is the remedy for this
ryan because you you just can't let this
keep happening and you know you have
democrats saying oh the cartels are
they're smuggling this through border
ports and entries and stuff it's not
true we see this every day they are
sending these drug mules across with a
lot of this fentanyl every single day
people who don't don't want to protect
the border say that everything's coming
through the port don't think for a
minute that these cartels are going to
change their business model
if they can't get it through the port
they're going to smuggle it underground
we've seen these
narco tunnels along our southwest border
they know where the vulnerabilities are
between the ports of entry and so people
that don't want to patrol the border
protect the border say it's all coming
through the ports that's just not true
they make a lot of seizures at the port
and i'm grateful for that but that's not
all of it yeah
it's interesting
ron thank you john vittiello thank you
so much have a great weekend